what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving into the most recent tragic
twist in the boku no hero story
a twist that gave many of us some deep
feels that we perhaps weren't exactly
expecting when this war arc started and
when we saw how much was at stake
I knew that sacrifices would have to be
made with this many intense battles
happening at the same time some
important characters would inevitably
end up losing their lives this was
indeed confirmed in the latest chapter
of the story and as the war art
continues I'm afraid that we need to
prepare ourselves for some more
potential sacrifices and more loss of
life anyway there is a lot to talk about
and to process so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
right here on the channel and you want
us to keep it go and please leave a like
to let me know it really does help and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that bell to turn on all notifications a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible with YouTube being as crazy as
ever patron support really means a lot
I'll talk more about our patrons at the
end of the video but now please be
warned that this video will contain boku
no hero manga spoilers as I already
mentioned we are dealing with the very
latest events in the boku no hero story
and the manga is far ahead of the anime
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned chapter 2 6 6 starts off in
the same epic moment that the previous
chapter ended with dobby ambushing Hawks
and scorching him with his deadly blue
flames however even though it had looked
very bad for Hawkes in the previous
chapter using his unbelievable speed
Hawkes is actually able to get away from
Darby's flames before he is completely
consumed by them
what's more Hawks actually grabs twice
and moves him out of the way of the
flames dobby was too busy trying to burn
Hawks to a crisp to even think about the
fact that twice was also gonna get
caught up in the crossfire with
I think gives us some pretty important
insight into Diaby psyche this man is
focused on one thing and one thing only
scorching heroes and he is not very
committed to things like friendship
camaraderie or actually promoting the
cause of the paranormal Liberation Front
now even though Hawkes managed to
withstand Abhi's initial attack he did
not come out of the exchange unscathed
in fact parts of Hawkes his body are
severely burnt and it seems that his
entire right wing has been burnt off as
Dobby points out many of the weapons
that Hawkes uses which are of course as
feathers have now been burned away and
so thanks to this surprise attack Hawkes
is nowhere near 100% in a matter of
seconds Hawkes went from full power to
severely weakened although thankfully
still alive
the injured Hawks notices that Dobby
doesn't seem at all surprised by hawks
his betrayal something that I mentioned
in my previous MHA video it's almost as
if Dobby expected this to happen and
Hawkes asks him outright whether Dobby
had figured out what was going on and
whether Hawkes his true mission had been
exposed without him even realizing it
but Dobby says that whether Hawkes was
exposed or not
Dobby never trusted him from the start
and this is the key takeaway for me
I don't think Dobby knew for sure that
Hawkes was a traitor I don't think he
had any evidence and so he couldn't
expose Hawks to the rest of the
Liberation Front but Dobby never trusted
Hawks
and let's face it he probably never
trusts anyone and that is why this
betrayal did not surprise him if you
literally never trust anyone
then you will never be caught off guard
when someone tries to betray you you
will always be expecting the worst case
scenario in his inner monologue Hawkes
acknowledges that his wings have been
severely burnt and this is bound to
greatly impede his ability to fly what's
more Hawkes has been cornered within a
fairly tight space by a villain whose
quirk allows him to basically scorch
everything around him and this is pretty
much the worst case scenario for Hawkes
being cornered within a tight space
without an escape route is an incredibly
difficult situation to be in
and this is basically the only scenario
in which Hawks cannot exploit his
superior speed to his advantage on top
of that Hawks cannot forget that
neutralizing twice and his insanely
overpowered quark has to be the priority
twice his sad man's parade is
potentially strong enough to ruin the
entire raid on its own if twice is able
to get away and launch the onslaught so
on top of worrying about dobby Hawks has
to do everything within his power to
prevent twice from unleashing his super
move Hawks notices that twice has also
been injured but not fatally despite
this major complication involving dobby
Hawks appears to still be determined to
capture Twice alive and to take him in
rather than just killing him for that
reason Hawks is still thinking about a
way to escape and take twice with him
but his options are narrowing quickly
Hawks simply cannot allow us to escape
under any circumstances because that
would mean that sad man's parade will be
unleashed upon the heroes but at the
same time Hawks
also doesn't want to kill twice because
he knows that deep inside twice is not a
bad person keep in mind that killing
twice is the only way to truly ensure
that the villain won't be capable of
posing an existential threat to the
heroes killing twice would also be a lot
easier than going through the trouble of
capturing him and literally carrying him
off to safety
especially with dobby ready to score
chocks at any moment and the fact that
Hawks is now seriously injured certainly
isn't helping but despite Hawkes telling
twice not to move and not resist twice
jumps out of the way and calls on dobby
to destroy Hawks with his flames dobby
unleashes the devastating power of his
quirk yet again and although twice
definitely feels the burn from the
flames he survives as for hawks it
doesn't appear that he was quite as
lucky because he seems to have taken a
direct hit he didn't get out of the way
and he didn't appear to have dodged the
flames in time thinking that the threat
posed by Hawks may have been eliminated
dobby tells twice to run out the door
and take on the heroes according to
dobby twice a lone could get rid of all
the heroes on his own under the right
circumstances and so twice runs off
the opposite direction from where Hawkes
had been standing before the flames
seemingly consumed him twice begins the
process of cloning himself over and over
again as he heads for the exit while
dobby continues to stand in the same
spot still cautiously watching the
aftermath of his attack on Hawkes
but then as twice in his clones head for
the door Hawkes suddenly flies in and
cuts off twice as escape route
it seems that Hawkes must have jumped
out the window just as Dhabi's flames
were rushing at him and he then flew
around the building in order to appear
again on the other side of the room
Hawkes appears to have carried all of
this out with only one functional wing
which is insane and asked twice screams
for him to get out of the way dobby
calls out to hawks and refers to him by
his real name
Hawks is surprised that dobby knows his
real name and he wonders who dobby
really is oh I don't know could it be
that dobby is actually toya Todoroki the
son of endeavor and he knows hawks his
true identity as a result of their
mutual connection to endeavor crazy
theory I know literally no one has ever
thought of this one before but let's
move on Hawks doesn't have much time to
think about da B's droid entity because
dobby unleashes yet another massive wave
of blue fire directly at the hero
meanwhile the injured twice is
determined to help the others to help
his friends he still feels responsible
for all of this for everything that
happened and he is desperate to protect
the people closest to him the League of
villains they are the only thing that he
lives for and he will do anything to
make things right
twice feels that his entire life has
been nothing but a series of failures
and getting tricked and backstabbed it
has been a pathetic and meaningless
existence for twice the only light at
the end of the tunnel have always been
his friends and he just can't let them
down now not again he can't live with
the guilt of allowing yet another one of
his friends to die due to his own
foolish and naive nature elsewhere
inside the mansion toga and mr. compress
are being attacked by a hero who shoots
giant snake
out of his wrists and it doesn't look
too good for them at the moment because
they both appear to be firmly trapped
inside the jaws of the snakes the hero
tells them to give up because this is
the end of the league of villains but
before the hero can finish his sentence
twice smashes him from behind and lays
him out flat toga and compress are both
happy to see twice and they thanked him
for rescuing them and compress tells
toga that they might as well just go
hide in the bunker now because twice is
about to take care of the heroes with
his epic shadow clone jutsu
clearly compress his high expectations
of twice and his newly reawakened cleric
but unfortunately for them twice has
some bad news
he can't clone himself in fact he can
barely hold himself together trying to
keep himself whole feels like trying to
hold in a big fart twice apologizes
again to his friends for allowing all of
this to happen
for allowing himself to be betrayed by
hawks thereby putting everybody in
danger Tolga and compressed aren't quite
sure what twice is talking about but
twice then approaches toga and returns
her handkerchief to her this is the same
handkerchief that toga had used to cover
twice his face after his mask had ripped
apart back then twice became mentally
unstable whenever he wasn't wearing his
mask and togas handkerchief gestures
saved him from losing his mind and
splitting apart during an important
moment in the story twice apologizes one
more time and he tells toga that he has
never made such a good friend as her in
that moment as he looks at togas shocked
face twice concludes that he has
actually led a really blessed life just
moments earlier twice had been thinking
that his entire life had been a series
of failures and just before that hawks
had said that twice was a good guy who
was dealt a bad hand in life however
upon seeing togas face twice changes his
mind and he changes his whole
perspective on life he says that his
life wasn't filled with bad luck in fact
he was happy to be here
he was happy as can be because he met
and got to know such great friends with
that twice his body disintegrates and
only the handkerchief remains it turns
out that back inside the room with hawks
and dobby when twice tried to escape the
room as dobby launched his fire blasts
at hawks hawks had managed to catch up
to the real twice and he had driven one
of his feather swords into the real
twice's body the real twice was killed
by hawks and only his final clones
arrived for long enough to save compress
and toga twice the real twice is dead
although to be fair we didn't actually
get to see the conclusion of that scene
in which twice actually died so we don't
know if it was Hawks who actually killed
him in the end or if it was maybe
Dhabi's flames we also don't know what
happened to Hawks in this moment it
definitely looks like Hawks caught up
twice and ended his life with one of his
feather swords although we don't
actually see the final moment but it's
important to remember that Dhabi's
flames were hot on hawks his trail did
Hawks managed to kill twice and get away
or did he actually sacrifice himself to
kill twice because taking the time to
kill twice actually allowed Dhabi's
flames to catch up to him my guess is
that horikoshi wouldn't kill off two
major characters within the span of like
two seconds so I'm thinking that Hawks
probably got away but we can't know for
sure until we see it with our own eyes
and unless all of this was some pretty
major major misdirection including fake
clones and Doctor Who Chico and who
knows what else it certainly appears
that regardless of what happened to
Hawks twice is definitely dead assuming
that this is true how will the villains
react now without a doubt
toga will be devastated compress and
spinner will be pretty sad but Dobby
Dobby could easily have been the one to
kill twice himself multiple times he
showed very little concern for twice a
safety and he launched his flames at
Hawks without thinking about the
collateral damage that might affect
twice Hawks even pointed this out to
Dobby telling him that his wanton
attacks were going to kill twice as well
but Dobby didn't seem to give this a
second thought
this chapter definitely gave us a lot to
think about it reminded us of what an
interesting complex character twice
turned out to be and even though he was
of course a villain who did bad
things I think that most of us are
feeling some degree of sadness for what
happened twice he was definitely a
deeply flawed character but he was also
a deeply human character and that made
him a unique and memorable villain this
chapter also gave us a stark reminder
about what kind of person Dobby truly is
and where his priorities lie unlike
twice
Dobby doesn't care about friendship he
doesn't care about his comrades and he
certainly doesn't care about the
paranormal liberation ideology bobbies
motivations are far darker and far more
sinister and they probably stem from his
traumatic childhood a childhood that we
technically don't know anything about
but a childhood that I'm willing to bet
involves our boy Angie Todoroki so what
does all of this mean for the rest of
the arc toga is about to lose it which
will most likely become a problem for
the heroes since togas quirk has also
awakened recently and she will be
anxious to use it in order to avenge
twice with that said twice his death is
a major blow for the villains because
now the massive threat posed by sad
man's parade has been neutralized Hawkes
has completed his mission although in
the end the mission might have caused
Hawkes a lot both physically and
mentally
not only is Hawkes severely injured or
worse but I'm sure that having to kill
twice after everything that the two of
them have been through together we'll
take a severe psychological toll on the
young hero for both the heroes and the
villains things will never be the same
again
let me know what you guys think what are
your thoughts on twice as a parent to
death and do the events of the chapter
change your opinion of either hogs or
dobby finally what do you think will be
the consequences of twice as death for
this war arc as a whole be sure to share
your thoughts with me down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the trouble of clicking the bell and
then selecting the option that says all
you're gonna miss a lot of our videos
it's just how you
works so if you want to make sure that
you are notified and that you stay up to
date especially since many of our videos
are time sensitive please subscribe and
hit that notification bell and select
that option that says all you can also
follow me on Twitter and or Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest channel
and boku no hero news and updates I want
to give a huge thank you to all of our
anime out pro patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
baby R a disciple of Lord we go himself
and I can't forget all are the one-tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata a lowland
Adam the world stealers the school bus
Tyson query know a quiet respect pat a
heffa and chris loki finally big thanks
to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing about a fan Jason Wilson Odin
Anatoly Cassatt's ki alpha do on hell
Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket
XP fitty dolla beat Ted no Ted Salter
Joe Stanton Larry Gucci Jessica Calif
and Alicia
dr. Levi Emperor otaku and JCCC waka if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]